oh my gosh I wow I have missed you guys
so much I have enjoyed the break I
just saw it at the commentary tried to
escape you saw me you did not try to I
try to get away from you I tried to ask
her I tried to know we were on the same
show I was in The Green Room wedding I
tried to Esther you Carlos was a witness
Carlos what happened yeah I was on the
same show you were but after when we
were in the the Bell you were standing
my boyfriend you were I had to see my
boyfriend you came up and started
talking about somebody I don't like you
that's not true
you don't like us I didn't say I said I
enjoyed the break Carlos no I'm just
kidding no no you guys I'm happy to see
you too I was kidding I was joking well
you saved me at The Comedy Store that
night you CR someone went is that kalila
and I just saw this little head peek it
was like a cartoon but you know what
happened I realized is that Bobby double
booked he had a date there that night
wait no I had yes Annie and that's why
he was going to different rooms at
different times because we had a
business meeting he deleted you
well no like we had a person like a we
had a business meeting there that we had
already set out to do and he couldn't
um cancel that business meeting so I met
a friend there that guy I told you I was
going to meet with Bob you should ah on
him and then he was like but I saw that
his energy was kind of like
such a weird reaction and then so he
would like us he was leaving he's on a
date you make it a date double date
and so when you saw me there he had just
left me to go escort his date out and I
told him like you don't have to do that
you just don't double book like next
time just don't double book you don't
have to I thought what happened is you
didn't know the times of our sets and
you invited people to come at the dregs
of the comic show and we were all done
you were like stay I was like [ __ ] I'm
out of here my set ended like an hour
ago she came late night where it was
like I don't know if you want to be here
later I didn't want to be there it's
that was the only time that this person
could meet that's her because he was
coming from Soho House was that Brad
Pitt it was
thank you to our sponsor rocket money
cancel unnecessary subscriptions with
rocket money today go to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday seriously it could save
you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday what if I
told you you could grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show go
to neutrophone.com use the code trash to
save 15 off your first month this is
their best offer anywhere only available
to us customers for a limited time free
shipping on every order that's 15 off at
nutrafol.com code trash
thank you to our sponsor Babel with
Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks and
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
trash Tuesday that's babble.com trash
Tuesday for up to 55 off your
subscription Babble language for Life
ZocDoc is a free app that shows you
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance and are available when
you need them go to zocdoc.com trash and
download the ZocDoc app for free then
start your search for a top-rated doctor
today many are available within 24 hours
that
zocdoc.com trash zocdoc.com trash
hi you guys I'm back on the road and I'm
going to be in Seattle Portland Phoenix
got rescheduled and San Francisco
Phoenix is not happening January 6th and
7th you guys can get tickets at Esther
onice.com and check out my solo podcast
my pleasure drops every Thursday
wherever podcasts are available hey
sluggies I am so excited I am going to
be at the Irvine Improv again for one
night only in a few days on the 20th I'm
so excited I'm bringing Jet Ski Johnson
I'm bringing Josh Potter and who else
who knows who else it's going to be so
fun please come let's tell this baby out
um I will then be at the San Jose Improv
November 11th and 12th and then I'm
doing a Michigan run December 1st
through the third I will also be in
Florida February 3rd through 4th and
many other dates are being added go to
annieleterman.com shows I cannot wait
[Music]
wait you guys I saw did you watch
Celebrity Jeopardy with Eliza no Eliza
won she it was Eliza Reggie Watts and
this guy that I love who is off the boat
um I never knew him until this show I
love Jeopardy I wouldn't I don't think I
would ever be brave enough to go on it
was like easy for them but still hard
for me like there was one that was like
18th century literature I was like I'm
out I would have just been like guys
thank you for having me I'll be in the
audience that's my time but my embiolic
I have my eye on you [ __ ] I'm coming
for you your mind I will I will have a
blossoming friendship if you know what I
mean
she will be mine I'm coming to college
did a good job hosting she's been
amazing hosting yeah Todd and I watching
her like this is like I I comment on one
of things I was like you're the best
thing to happen in Jeopardy since Alex
Trebek's mustache remember when that
went first R.I.P is mustache first it
was like Alex okay wait well she's like
a real life genius she's a genius the
way she delivers the lines it's like you
have to be so smart just to read the
questions but she's got both in green
she's genius and she's a good actress
I think the three of us as one
contestant could do well on Jeopardy no
I think I think donut might have a shot
compared to the rest I think we should
get on Family Feud can do listen I love
intelligence so bad well let's do my
work with Steve Harvey I did I did man
on the street for the Steve Harvey Show
when he used to have the Steve Harvey
Show and he loved me I did only go once
do our show oh my God we yes we need
Lori Harvey on we need to learn from her
wait you know Steve Harvey technically
oh close the entire Philippines in
apology when he read the wrong winner at
Mrs brilliant but it brought it brought
it highlighted she really was the most
famous Miss Universe the Philippine the
one unbelievable yeah we're supposed to
start a wholesome three I feel like we
kind of just nailed it yep is that three
yeah three minutes with no
bad words no no Saucy no no mention of
holes wait I have to see what this I
have to see if you know that's one [ __ ]
though was that may was it for me yeah
yeah yeah anyway all Asians 91. Eddie
Wong is so awesome this is my first this
was my first introduction to him
sunglasses on the entire show he was the
best and then at the end I'm gonna
spoiler alert the end on Jeopardy the
end of Jeopardy wait Eliza beat him
Eliza beat everyone he would he crushed
the Vegas one it happened to Vegas it
was so funny he made all these Vegas
jokes he was I will say no offense to
anyone else it's not a competition on
Comedy but he was the funniest one he
was being so funny everyone was being
great but Reggie had the best joke at
the end he they asked like you know in
this like 18th century uh book it
highlighted these two characters or
whatever and he he wrote Thelma and
Louise that's his final answer but it
was Jekyll and Hyde and Eliza won hard
Eliza won hard and she was like she was
like rubbing it in their face like you
could see they were starting like gang
up against her like Eliza you're going
down it was great wow and is a really
bright guy too he was on Vice he's been
on everything he's perfect I'm sorry I
didn't know who you were I didn't watch
why you say you guys I
have to
come forward with a story that is so
hard to share I didn't even really tell
Carlos the whole story I guess she asked
did you doo-doo your pants no but that's
a really good guess who would have told
me that that's a really intuitive I feel
like Carlos would have changed her
diaper
diaper we have to do this
I came back from the Philippines last
night give me a break guys oh you're a
virgin the accent's heavy we will get to
that but I this actually is more
important
yesterday did a tick tock go bad I did
someone not like your tick tocky met
Kendall Jenner
and it did not go out it did not I
really needed my girls there did you
think that she followed you on Tick Tock
no I definitely did you go I need to see
what you eat like this is really
important how did you open so I went to
you bombed with Jordan Woods okay how
bad did you bomb with Jordan wood not
that bad
you were a weird creep behind me like I
was blocking your whole body I was like
can my friend take a picture with you
that's a bomb and then you scooched
ahead and it was not a good picture it
gets worse okay if you think that was
bad you did not use your tire Banks uh
notes no that was that one went well I
was invited to this push Kourtney
Kardashian Wellness event and I was like
oh my God this is so cool like I this is
such a big deal I was so excited
I go and it's like really fancy it's at
this fancy house in West Hollywood
there's free air one smoothies there's
like free facials and they they're
giving girls makeovers and stuff and I
see Kris Jenner right and I'm like oh my
God like that's her I get a selfie was
she little
she looked no no surprises but she did
look oh you're two feet tall I forgot
I'm glad you're trying do they all look
Kendall so tall like so tall that it
really made the interaction far worse
than it needed to be but basically so
she does not even see you you're like
hello hello one of the producers of
their Hulu show which was filming
actually knew me she was like oh Esther
like I love your comedy like and we
started talking she was like I know
you're like obsessed with the
Kardashians she's like I'm obsessed with
the comedy we're like opposite ends I'm
like oh my God that's so cool I was like
I love can I date one of them can you
get Chris to put set me up with one of
them I was like gosh I sure would love
to like invite one of the girls to like
come to a stand-up show at The Comedy
Store she's like you totally should
she's like you should I'm like oh really
like are you sure I'm like should you
ask like your boss she's like I and she
should go she asked her boss and her
boss is like yeah she's like my boss
who's like the executive producer of the
Hulu Kardashian shows like she just said
go ask her so I'm like okay like the
boss said to do it so
Kendall and her two friends are like
standing right literally where you guys
are and they're all tall one of them is
short and the short one I could tell hey
to me yeah don't even try to be the
short pitch
short one was like not even no eye
contact so I go from like hi I'm Esther
um I'm a stand-up comedian do you guys
want to come to my comedy show oh my God
and they just looked at me like
obviously the way you look at a scary
person who's coming up to you for no
reason and
um Kendall's assistant started to engage
in conversation oh and it felt a little
bit like she was just trying to like
calm the crazy person down she was like
oh you do comedy
nice you oh you sound like you opened up
I invited them to an open mic I'm aware
what I did no I made it sound like I was
doing a bringer show and I needed six
friends you have to be your grossest
self-winning celebrity you have to name
drop people they know you have to be
like you have to do it like this really
fast you have to I'm telling you you
have to if you're you have to be like
when I met I know Jeff Probst isn't
quite the same too but he is my my
Kardashians I need to learn from this
I'm telling you I had to go I was on Joe
Rogan the other day
hi my name is on the wall of the comedy
score I'm one of the greatest I'm one of
the greats I'm one of the top people I
love you you're my guy I never act like
this around anyone but I just like love
what you do it's so amazing blah blah
blah
I needed you there so bad well okay well
no I would have just taken the heat I
would have been like to the assistant
could she just talked to her all time
Carlos thank God he wasn't there they
would have called the [ __ ] police it
would have been done I'd be like what is
this person it was so uncomfortable I
still would have been like two minds
like um getting on all four so I can
actually use you as an Apple box and
stand up and try to make sure my friend
asks that I put it what if I came over
and you're on my shoulders I think that
would have been like Papa daughter bro
like read a parade it was so not good
and I have to shout out Rumor Willis who
I saw there who I actually have met once
before thank God she was so nice and
treating me like a person she was like
hey it's more sad on her honestly rumor
are you okay
do you need help we had a very lovely
conversation it was really just like the
Kendall energy and I I want to say I
take full responsibility but what did
she say that she just it was like I
don't think she's radio or something I
think she might have said that's nice or
like oh cool like it was I doubt she
even gave you that I feel like your your
ego is like giving you something no
there was some words muttered but she
was surprised I'm sure there were the
thing is she's so far up there that it's
hard for me to even have heard what she
said all the way down here but I just
want to say I claim I take full
responsibility this is not some like
Kendall Jenner was mean to me I was a
fool I acted crazy and I want to
formally apologize to Kendall not to her
short friend though I know that you
or just didn't want me you guys need to
stick together honestly you need to
literally stick together like on each
other with a jacket around you
but and then on my way out I I saw
Courtney walking in I just was like love
this smoothie she's like really and that
was my that was my I that was I'm not
okay
[Laughter]
I need help this my we gotta we'll just
make it happen it's okay I feel very
it's fine you have a good thing to talk
to him about next time like remember
when I was a loser last time I talked to
you you know that energy where you feel
like you've been sent back to the mail
room
like that's how I feel m-a-l-e
um look at my shirt while you were at
the Kardashians thing I was at Colusa
Casino partying my ass off blow me for
like wait but Annie I want to know what
what do you think you would have said to
Kendall
how can you write this wrong for me
if I were you or just if you were there
I would have climbed I would have been
standing on something if I were you to
be like equal but if you were there what
would I've done for you yeah what would
you have or what would you have been
like we host a podcast like yeah would
you ever I would have been like where
wait you so you think it's better to be
like will you do my podcast so you don't
say do it you just say
you also there is like an error where
you almost have to like act like they
know who you are and it seems or they
have to know who you are or they should
you just have to have confidence you
can't be just rolling over there like
I do you know me from the ding dong show
when I was 21. you're acting like a
[ __ ] 13 year old koyla what would you
have done nothing I would have stood in
the corner just like I saw her at The
Comedy Store humiliated I saw her at the
comedy store she would have been
standing in a question like this this
honestly I was like Annie I'm not even
kidding she appeared for like it was
like I hide I hide I try to stay in
there which is very tall she's like a
hot you're like who's the hot hovering
girl but in the darkest corner of the
room where the red lights aren't quite
hitting so that's where I'll you know
I'll just recede back into the darkness
is usually what I do is anyone here
proud of me for trying I really am of
course no you got my shot it's just the
first shot okay okay it's gonna be fine
there's no issues here okay Carlos what
do you think I'm not proud because
it's like what would you have done
kissed her no it's like the bare minimum
what is kissed her you know what you
know exactly what it is oh the kissing
Carlos
what you did to Kyle was unfair to
kalilah
you forced her you said earlier pulled
the tampon out you said never when he
almost kissed the tampon instead I know
I know you she saved you I thought
that's what it was the whole agreement I
was like oh I'm gonna suck on a tampon
and we'll have some laughs for this day
I feel like you've sucked on so many
times but this is such a tampon sucker
anyway
do you guys ever wonder why it's so hard
to cancel any subscription it's so
annoying also I got one just randomly
canceled on me my yoga just cancel me
I'm like this is the only Honest Company
I haven't been there in six months
they're like we'll just cancel it for
you I'm like I I mean I'm telling you
I'm still in like battles for when they
just turned my my subscription back on
for I was a prescription I would say in
the last week I have signed up for like
four new subscriptions that I don't even
know why I don't know how I certainly
don't know how to cancel them like it is
so stressful the where economy is
treating us do you know how bad how many
times I've done like because I just
started intermittent fasting so I got
like oh maybe I'll take like a fasting
quiz online you know they're like free
fasting quiz and then you get to the end
and they're like sign up for 7.99 or 4
000 a year and you're like and you've
already taken the 20 minute quiz yeah I
feel like [ __ ] it I want to see what the
results are We're Not Alone by the way
80 of people have subscriptions that
they just simply forgot about maybe
that's you maybe that's all of us here
it could be an unused Amazon Prime
account a Hulu account that never gets
streamed there is an app that we all use
that helps us track our expenses and
because of it we're not wasting money on
subscriptions that we don't even use and
it's rocket money which is formerly
called true bill and most Americans
think that they only spend eighty
dollars a month on subscriptions when
the actual total was actually closer to
200 that's a lot that is a little for me
honestly guys I'm way higher than that
also rocket money can help you find
subscriptions that you didn't even know
you had which is really scary and the
app shows all of your subscriptions in
one place and cancels what you don't
want for you rocket money can even find
subscriptions you didn't know you were
paying for and you may even find out
you've been double charged for a
subscription something Annie knows a lot
about so bad to cancel a subscription
all you have to do is press cancel and
Rocket money takes care of the rest
cancel unnecessary subscriptions with
rocket money today go to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday seriously it could save
you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com slash
trash Tuesday
Annie when people are constantly asking
you what's your hair secret why is your
hair so much better what do you tell
them now I tell them neutral baby I love
it I mean it's amazing all my meet and
greets are always like girls feel it
feel it it's thickening up I mean they
hadn't thought it before but I'm like
guys I swear on my life this is my
product I've known you for 10 years
there's such a difference in your hair
since we found neutrophil I'm so proud
that they sponsor our show because this
is a product I've literally heard the
coolest people I've ever met talking
about it organically so I know more
eavesdropping on Kendall
sensitive what I love about neutralfold
2 is that they're not promising an
overnight fix you know it's legit when
it takes a while to see the results
neutriful is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage neutral supports healthy
hair growth from within by targeting the
five root causes of thinning address
hormones environment nutrition and
Metabolism through the whole body health
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
neutrophil.com and entering the promo
code trash to save 15 off your first
month's subscription this is their best
offer anywhere and it is only available
to us customers for a limited time and
plus free shipping on every order but
you guys in the stats itself 86 percent
of women reported improved hair growth
after six months that's 86 percent those
stats are amazing neutrophil has three
unique formulas to support women through
all stages of life including postpartum
and menopause each formula is physician
formulated using natural drug free
medical grade ingredients in
consistently effective dosages so that
you can get the most reliable results 3
000 plus Top Doctors and stylists
recommend neutrophil as an effective and
high quality solution for healthier hair
you guys can get 15 off at
neutrophil.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code
trash
that's it that's it
Esther Now esther asked me the other day
she's like what do you think we can do
to like spice things up and I have an
idea and it's something I already
brought in but everyone kind of ignored
it but I have an idea and you have to
agree to it before you before I oh do
you want the show to do well or not I do
okay
get your ankles and your wrists ready to
get tied up while we unleash donut on
you I'm honestly down for that this is
what this is the type of yes it is I
don't know what a hog tie is it's a hug
tie she knows the names of things I
thought you would freak I'm helping you
there's some sort of like sexual tension
right now no no no it's between you
Carlos but you calling me a freak is
like I'm trying to help you people do
not understand when you're trying to get
them laid I hate to be the Esther of the
show today but I really do have a
stomachache
is it from all the drama around the kiss
do you need olives maybe is it emotional
olives to olives help no I just said um
I so for 37 years of my life I hated
olives and then one day
um a little bit after the breakup I
Started Loving olives
oh my God no it's because of me that you
love olives no we only bonded after that
she's never getting a tattoo of her name
but it's so sad she kissed Carlos yeah
perfect she kissed Carlos over you you
understand that but like okay wait a
second what is the update is it is it
fading at all not at all everyone I meet
is like you've been fooled they love to
bring up that I it's not that it is a
real tattoo oh yeah it's darker than
it's been exactly a year all the other
ones are fading a little though except
most sleepovers secretly wait I got a
new one wait Carlos oh I got one too
wait is yours a fake one too yeah Sonny
what do you think wait hold on I got
what I think yours is I got my pleasure
for my solo podcast and also to
emphasize emphasize living my life for
my pleasure when have you not I've never
had someone that's not living more her
[ __ ] pleasure are you kidding me
[ __ ]
it is crazy
this is crazy
wait wait till you see believe me that
was just the warm-up wait till you hear
Carlos's tattoo is it of your name it's
way better oh it's a nice piece I like
it I like it I love it I like it I love
it too I like it cool I don't dislike it
in any way Esther on the other hand the
gay guy did it it was it was it's
redundant I think your attitude shows us
this is feels so good to squish around a
bag of Olives what makes you think what
what make what do you think
is it because you were like sad and
someone just slipped an olive in your
mouth or I think one time I was crying
and like hadn't eaten in two days and
then all that was available was um
airplane olives and I couldn't buy food
anywhere I was like [ __ ] and I was just
like [ __ ] then the olives came with like
the snack pack and I ate it I was like
this is [ __ ] delicious they're salty
they're a little sour they're right it's
healthy fat it's very satisfying I'm
like is it a hot girl food it is you
know what I was thinking why it's so
good that you do the hot girl and ugly
girl Foods because you are equally both
so I'm the one I'm the authority on it
the thing is you're 100 hot and 100 ugly
[Laughter]
I walk
on a wall you've been walking I've been
walking well it's just because I keep I
got reset again I knew I had like a
noose Annie what yellows because I think
I had to take so many antibiotics and
now my body's like [ __ ] you better not
do nothing bad because you're going yeah
thanks well what happened for me was
usually when I go back to the
Philippines I always get some form of
diarrhea always like without fail
because how come you don't say diarrhea
like diarrhea diarrhea she does is that
a diaper no it's diaper and diarrhea
okay I wanted more but it's okay
um anyways I usually
um I'm usually sick either I get a
parasite or amoebiasis or something that
causes baby asses is the name you can
pick up an amoeba and it's called amoebi
asses yeah
you know that Annie isn't mature enough
for words like that so that's on you I
dare you to tell me what it's called
when someone plays the piano
never not laughed at that piano player
for Anne don't be stupid
scream it it's the thing you're not
attracted to a 12-inch penis
um and then I was really just really
proud of myself I was on the plane we
were about to land I was like oh my God
no diarrhea and I got home and there was
no food at all so I made myself
um you know those um chicken nuggets
those frozen chicken nuggets are not
very good I made a ton of rice I put a
ton of sriracha and that was a mistake
you guys I woke up with straight up
diarrhea and my stomach is not
recovering well so Frozen American food
is what's getting me this time okay
she's back she's gone back she's now
full Filipina yeah Ari how did you feel
reconnecting with the Homeland I usually
go every year except I haven't been
since the pandemic can I see your big
fat ass you're asking fat in a good way
I mean this not really that yes it's
better yes
he trunked up we should call it trunk
Tuesday her abs are rock hard no they
aren't you guys I was just starving a
little over there she's like I want to
feel like home again
but do you feel okay so for me when I go
to Skokie you know touch touch ground of
my homeland like touch cloth immediately
shits her pants she's like Mommy will
clean the poopy out of my butt
for my pleasure
your parents must spit on that spit on
your tattoo are you [ __ ] kidding me
[ __ ] as they're folding all your
laundry
he's ready to take care of herself huh
she's ready to focus on me at least I'm
okay with very little right like I just
all I need is just because it's small
you're just small that's what it is
I'm just curious do you feel oh my God
you are a Frogger in your parents house
you're frogging your own family no
that's my goal
my goal is to [ __ ] be in Vegas
this has like jizz stains on it I don't
know it's like oh it really does have a
jizz stain it's making me uncomfortable
you know our house I feel like you
should um try and frog do you know who
Dana White is he's like the president of
the UFC yeah I don't know why I was like
it can't be Dana White yes I feel like I
don't know for some reason I feel like
that's a match for you to frog
Vegas energy he has like that kind of
just like all-nighter energy yes I'm so
embarrassed I didn't remember Eddie's
name Eddie Bravo or yeah
Huang Huang don't
did I say it wrong no we said I died
earlier
um but Esther to you to your question
I'm kindling
okay
we cannot come up randomly it's too
dramatic
imagine how dramatic it is for them
they're like that [ __ ] little boy
came up to us that looks like the guy
from what do the people tell you you
look like what's the cartoon character
you look exactly like that oh no wait
you're the hot version you're like the
sexy version sexy grew for Halloween
but wait by the way are we doing a
Halloween episode what's going on I
don't know Carlos P the oh is that
called you thieves
Theo on the mine
just pile them on me
yes everybody
did you reconnect with the Homeland or
not this is the first time I've truly
related to you Esther was going home
because
um I felt you know you go home because
you want your nappy changed yeah I
that's what that's how I felt and I live
with your mom don't you no kind of but
you do kind of my mom you're with your
mom so often oh she lives in L.A or any
but she's changing her nappy are you
changing your nappy now
I need to change I oh my God she's wait
a minute she's recruiting how do you
think I live with my mom no but yeah my
mom do you know how hard it would be for
me to see my mom for you to just you're
like every time I see your mama's me
okay I I wanna
number one you went to a family party my
mom was there you're right you're right
the other thing maybe invite me over a
little more [ __ ] maybe that's the only
time I'm allowed over is when everyone
else is invited
where would I invite you to oh yeah also
can people on my Tick Tock live stop
asking me to stop filming my podcast in
Bobby Lee's garage I don't film it there
okay it's more of a cinnamon it's not
filming it's more of a recording we know
we don't film this and I'm so store nice
we are guys she's a liar Kendall she
lies early in a different city we don't
film there anymore we are in Las Vegas
Nevada we're in Dana White's garage Dana
White's Adam and also I'll do anything
thing I want in Bobby Lee's garage okay
so is that a threat yeah or a promise
and she's squirting I just hear I don't
know why I see you doing like a crab
walk but squirting out ew that is so
disturbing do you want to meet a Kendall
do you want to meet a Kendall in your
life you need to stick with me kid
[Music]
where were we the Philippines was really
nice okay yeah it was really nice I
think
I didn't go with my mom she didn't come
no no at this time because we were just
there to work Bobby and I was Bobby was
there for like half of the time I was
there but when he left is when the fun
really started for me just because it's
like I got to be with my family a lot
but it's that same feeling you know like
home like no matter what you're always
going to want to go home to Skokie and
you're always going to want to go home
to your family and you kind of never
stop to think why I don't think your
brain chooses your body chooses where
home is you start to just kind of like
I've never laughed harder in my life
like my family I'm so mean decided to
girls
you don't even consider it no not wow
Kendall's never coming to one of your
shows Kendall I'm a hundred percent no
100 of the time she isn't even sure of
herself but do you know what I mean it's
like I'm sure you guys feel as we're
like you're around a lot of comics all
day but no one makes you laugh as hard
yeah a million people that you love well
you have to match match like it's like
matching your comedy vibration exactly
it's like when I see you laugh when your
dad says something is a different kind
of laugh than when I hear you yeah I
hear you laughing yeah comic that's how
I feel when I go home that's why I go
home for the laughs like so I totally
relate to that yeah and it's kind of
this like borderline like laughs all the
elves
it's kind of like this borderline
traumatic kind of Joy you're having
where it's like wait this is like the
purveyor of all of my hurt but somehow
like it's all good so hilarious and
chaotic like just it was never ending
just like cackling and laughing and
obnoxious energy and I just like
couldn't get enough of it I think that's
what makes best friends too it's like
your best friends can mimic that like
family level laughter where you're just
like crying laughing do you feel renewed
or like you know post breakup post trip
home like where she's like are you
leaving
are you moving uh you think you'll
commit to another year to get a job at
uh where did you work again Johnny
Rockets Johnny Rockets again I
um it's both uh the last day that I was
there I was like crying like it's not
Bubbles and everything because you know
you just don't wanna you just want to
stay home it's where you feel safe it's
where you just want to be I get I got my
hair brushed every night do you know
that kind of like by who level of my
friends my sister my cousins like we're
a really big like girl gang there so I
just always had someone to like like
coddle me almost every night it was your
dream can I go to they're not combing
your hair [ __ ]
don't try to sneak in you try to do that
with Kendall Jenner and it failed yeah
maybe I should just keep to myself it's
so funny if you did the same thing
happened with her family just every time
you go up to people they're like yeah I
get handled by everyone
um my family's real like they can take a
lot like they can take any type of super
big energy because they're super big
energy too so you can throw anything at
them and they'll be like yeah we like
her we love her we'll take care of her
we'll brush her hair so yeah
let's
talk about Vegas
it's all I think about I dream about it
it's the lights the ding ding ding ding
ding ding everything but fun Vegas
season is kind of over
but now when it's like finally not so
hot all the time
excuse me explain yourself
I didn't like going to Vegas in the
winter because
um number one
um I guess you know you guys are in
relationships but there's lesser Talent
too there's lesser Talent around like in
the summer you have all of like the
Europeans the Australians and everyone
coming on their break and in the winter
with Australian boys we're still turned
on by that I don't know I'm not sure it
used to be an automatic for me and I
think I grew it's like skaters
what I don't think so okay that was hot
we love Australians I'm not saying I
don't love us Trends but um like that
automatic they just have the accent and
you're wet New Zealand accent I think
like taika white TT you know one of my
biggest regrets is when I was in New
Zealand I didn't go to this strip club
when were you in New Zealand
and she had tonsillitis yeah oh yeah
that was when we bonded it was like
eight years ago you are so the [ __ ]
Queen creep that creep actually Rose or
whatever her name was the girl that
pretended to be sick and a baby I'm just
so sad because there was a strip club in
New Zealand that we didn't go to and it
was the it was American Presidents
themed no and I still oh wait strip club
yes oh and I'm still just like what
could that have been oh get a little lap
dance from Abe Lincoln it's just a chick
with like a beard with no mustache too
sick to go who are you there with Dave
yeah
huh would he have wanted to go he was
down yeah he was down anything to get me
to leave the hotel you are the worst
but okay I'm not kidding you and I know
we always say this it's been like a year
and a half of this I get it but I'm very
I am very serious
just a one-nighter I'm going to Vegas
next weekend next weekend skank Fest
but like a a different trip I'm it's
four hour drive it's a 10 minute flight
so you're saying you're always down I've
never not been down I think we could get
kalila to do a one night in Vegas with
us I I think that's possible yeah who do
you think is the one that yeah it holds
a Meester
you guys thinking it's me it's crazy
look at her looking up like a liar she's
like
me I am all
I'm old potato [ __ ] we gotta get we
have to roll you I'm not saying I'm
gonna leave my room but I want to be hey
guys the same time as you guys oh my god
let's go without her oh my God you would
die that's actually the best prank ever
to just everyone except Esther goes we
get donut to come look at Donut's little
push with the stiff arm
know all the donito do you want to eat
your mom's butthole out while she's tied
up so gross she would never wait she
would when do we plan on hog tying you
it's happening I feel like Carl should
get home during the banana bread listen
I said Todd I go how does this not end
with Carlos being tied easy no look can
I see this
Todd's like is this for me or for you I
was like Todd it's so disgusting you're
saying that but I did tie him up and
it's done it was so funny I think Lila
can I have it it is that no we're using
it but I tied Todd up with it today and
he was starting to fall off the bat he
was like no it's gonna hurt and you just
I filmed it I just pushed him he's like
no I'm the meanest girlfriend why don't
I think kalila should put it on Carlos
it's right there
it's right here oh I was like I will
kill God Todd's Fire doesn't have to pay
oh wow it's like industrial Grid it's so
good but you can reach them that's the
annoying part it's like you're not
really trying Alice come here no it's
got to be you I have a new pair of
airports but we'll do him too but he'll
be the open mic of it you're on Deck
okay ew don't okay you don't know like
oh I just kissed my lady before I go
where does this go Annie this is part
two we'll have to well I haven't done
this before we'll black out his body
will be like who's the mystery person
getting hogtied well this is for your
wrist I think the other ones are your
ankles I just want to say to the fans
you guys are such nerds if you are
falling for all of this no we say kalila
forced who did kalila Force who is who
did kalila rape today can you guys guess
he's got a silly hairdo
Carlos about that kiss by the way I
really wasn't expecting you to slip
tongue like you did oh
squat down for me baby
he peed a little in her mouth did you
guys see that that's the part I think
it's really [ __ ] up
you know what's so funny is they're like
when people are like I can't believe
kalila kissed Bobby's friend I'm like
do you think Carlos and Bobby are just
chilling
and he just like pulls out they're not
friends he doesn't like he he is
officially tied what do we do with him
push him push him get out of his stomach
he's got a good corset I'm not doing the
stomach well then ghetto it is gay
honestly
we gotta put like peanut butter on have
no stop not on extra Idols it doesn't
have to be his genitals wait how do you
feel wait maybe we can unbutton can we
throw olives at them or something oh
wait can you try to catch olives in your
mouth that's insane Why without your
hands that's fun okay
um I knew you're gonna like that's what
I like you know what I love about Carlos
he says no so adamantly and then the
next time he goes okay
your game you're fun are you able to
um knee your way back to your mic or no
all right are you
can I give you like a your ability to
orchestrate a chaotic
oh he's got another kiss if he gets a
man
a kiss are people really angry about our
kids who cares
yeah these people are they actually
don't care is this like WWE at this
point you guys this is like
too
much
that feels like I like do like an arc I
feel my saliva oh my God look at those
juicy lips gorgeous juicy lips
that made me a little horny I'm not
gonna lie the weight
too that's the thing she wants to win
she wants to win she's been refreshed by
her people
oh I like how she closed her mouth
oh my God she Asian mom do the word
fetishes
oh Donut's like let me see what's going
on a Donut's like I'll take Donuts you
look out we always call Randy brush when
his face you want to be untied now or
what's your safe word
Santino's gonna kick your ass I don't
think it's gonna be Esther who will help
you out of that you can get out yourself
oh yeah
oh my God it's right you can reach it
I'll help you but
realize
we just realized that that should be our
next thing IBO the next tattoo so people
the other unobvious thing I have Bo I'm
stinky
don't you hate when you're like is there
a hoagie oh my God it's my armpits wait
you guys yeah I like meal guys I'm
nervous speaking of Bo smelling like
Hoagies I have a wawa Cup coming she's
making me a Wawa one from the color I
don't know we'll see can I smell your Bo
yeah who's which one of us is getting up
I'm I am nervous like just give me the
truth I guess
[Music]
it is Bo but I I I like it I feel like I
run jonbenet's actual shoes
for the record these are the hottest
shoe of the Season they're the but in a
size like toddler one they are a size
four which has imported from Singapore
oh my God I'm proud of you that made me
hornier than their little Olive thing
when you went to Italy how useful was
Babel before your trip okay well I can't
speak for myself because I didn't know
about Babel yet but my best friend who
went with us literally was learning
Italian and I was like this is genius
this is my new goal I'm going to for the
next trip I take I'm going to study with
Babel before I go I hope it's Paris I
want to just learn some of the basics
and I want to be able to have
conversations there because it seemed so
empowering to be able to have that and
Babel makes it so actually achievable
with Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use AI for
their lesson plans but Babel lessons
were created by over 150 language
experts and voiced by real native
speakers not computers their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective and with Babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including Spanish French Italian and
German plus Babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation creation and accent
there's so many ways to learn with Babel
in addition to lessons you can access
podcast Games videos stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20
money day money 20 day money back
guarantee and you can start your new
language learning Journey today with
Babel I have a English maybe you can
learn that
I it literally makes me so happy because
I've my whole life I'm not kidding you
guys I felt like learning a new language
is just something that I'll never be
able to do that I just don't have that
brain power with Babel it is a game
changer I'm learning small slowly
it's a little Italian so I'm just really
proud and grateful that I'm starting to
use this and I'm really enjoying you'll
be able to understand the news when
you're sitting in the hotel room
wherever we go
and right now you can get up to 55 off
your subscription when you go to
babel.com trash Tuesday that's
babble.com trash Tuesday for up to 55
off your subscription Babble language
for life and it's b-a-b-b-e-l I've been
waiting for an app like this for so long
it's like I it's so hard to just blindly
choose a doctor and have full faith in
that person I want to know what other
people think about them what their you
know what their experience has been with
this doctor before I you know pull the
trigger on them I'm so upset that I
didn't have ZocDoc earlier like it has
changed my relationship with the medical
community because like you said you know
how many times I've gone to a doctor and
I'm like this was a terrible experience
this is a waste of my money my time
finding parking I go to her doctor
because I needed a doc doc she's she was
my ZocDoc before I knew about soccer I
just you need someone else to tell you
whether the doctor's good or not and we
do it with everything else yeah we get
before we walk talking to a restaurant
before we do anything we usually read
the reviews hotels everything else will
die now we have it for doctors when I
had my sinus infection which literally
asked her is the one that diagnosed me I
went to I had to go to urgent care
because our doctor was out of town sir
uh it was kind of a long one
um and he was so rude the place I go to
it because there's never a line because
this man is so mean he's mean and if I
knew I would never have gone to him
zocdoc's mobile app is as easy as
ordering a ride to a restaurant or
getting delivery to your house search
find and book doctors with a few taps
you can also find and review local
doctors read verified patient reviews
from real people who made real
appointments now when you walk into that
doctor's office you're all set to see
someone in your network who gets you you
just do a little tap tap to get that pap
pap go to zocdoc.com trash and download
the ZocDoc app for free then start your
search for a top-rated doctor today and
many are available within 24 hours
that's
zocdoc.com
trash zocdoc.com trash
yes my girl's getting it she's getting
it oh by the way I didn't realize that
the dress that you wore at Benji's
wedding is your friend's line and I've
been obsessed I've been looking at oh I
didn't even like look at her I don't
know why it didn't even occur to me to
look at her website I was looking at all
of it she is talented that stuff is so
beautiful he is like the queen of
Celebration I gotta get rid of my back
roll because all of them are backless
but once I'm rid of that back row girl
I'm coming for you get right now the
American Express Church you know what
top I have of hers it's the uh yeah it's
the turtleneck crop top the tie on the
side I literally colored her I was like
when is this coming it's that's out of
stock I literally almost ordered I have
one the red one's really pretty I know I
was like which color should I get but
I'm like it really like it would be so
back real high you need to do an Rumi
themed episode we do and she um she has
an old daddy yeah old sperm yes get her
on the show
she um no is she too cool for us well
she could do the show she's we can just
wear the clothes she's definitely not
too cool for us but that doesn't mean
that I think for sure she would do like
she's so like a creative fairy all the
time like I don't know I never know so
pretty she's stunning I saw her at
Erawan and I was like who is oh everyone
I've ever seen at Arrow and I go
agar on there once and was like I know
there's a little human and you don't
it's like people that you know are
pretty but then you see them at arowan
you're like there's an extra glow it's
like did you have the Haley Bieber is
that what it is no but Rumi actually
offered to design my wedding dress and
that's is that why you changed your last
name at first sign I've ever been like
okay I actually might have a wedding
wait that's what I wanted to ask you are
you secretly married no my dad asked me
that last night he's like are you
married or something that's the first
thought I had because that's how little
we think of you because you we know you
won't even consider inviting us to it
here's what you guys do without us for
your pleasure here's why I thought it
here's why I thought it because like
right after you change your handle to
Esther King
Dave posted a picture of you and in your
hand it looked like there was a wedding
band and I know it was in your middle
finger but I was like ah if Esther would
put a wedding band on the middle finger
so let me see the middle finger to say
[ __ ] you to straight relationships well
so I did change my name I do think I
want to start going by Esther King but
I'm doing things out of order I'm gonna
change my name for you to have kept
you're long
truly annoying I might not even know it
at this point last name when it could
have been King for so many years is
actually I'm offended at this I have to
say I'm on your side it was Esther King
is like that's what everyone like people
are responding so positively to it that
I'm like wow so I also thought he might
have like threatened to kill you and
there was like a near-murder suicide
because of how much [ __ ] you talk on
this podcast no he would never uh he no
he like barely noticed or cared and was
just like whatever but it's cute it's
like the best last name I'm so glad you
guys like it yeah I'm into it and like I
said I I'm I think if I'm gonna approach
marriage at all um it's gonna all be
like out of order and chaotic and random
and not make sense and so that's why I'm
like I'm gonna change the name first and
just like see how that get divorced
first
I want to have a shotgun wedding like
with a rando okay I like that energy for
me I love a Vegas midnight wedding
you're not a rando at this point you've
already had a full-blown relationship on
the internet with her but everyone seems
to know about it you guys are watching
wrestling you do get that right okay
I did almost have like a random um
affair with um a local fisherman and
then it turned out he was your cousin
you're like many of my family members
yeah I actually want to tell you you
have a ban on [ __ ] anyone on your
Island I can't have you [ __ ] other
family member you know the chances of
them being related to me is high because
my mom has like 10 siblings so there's a
good chance um yeah but um there was
this fisherman who took me to this like
very he no one is supposed to dive where
he took me but he was like oh such a
move for you he was like really
impressed with like my breath holds and
he was like let me take you to a spot
he really was he was I mean like
his whole life is Under the Sun so he
had like kind of bleached hair and like
lighter eyes really tense does the Sun
change her eye color yeah over time
and so um can he was telling me all like
the scientific names of the different
fish that he fishes and he was like see
if you can see this that's right down
there and so I I would die but I could
be like what is this grouper with this
spot and he would tell me the name and
we were just doing this for like a whole
hour and no one else was there
I made the mistake and asked them if he
you know I started asking about his
family he was like oh I have two kids
and I was like I'm out oh but this is
like Zoom I'll just hold the hand up
okay I'll go next
um is your safe word grouper
this is reminding me a lot of an
experience I had once with a Cemetery
groundskeeper where like we remember
like he took an interest in me and like
we remember we thought he thought you
escaped from the grave you don't
remember this and he was like how did
the corpse from JonBenet is it yearly
just saw your feet
gave me he he took an interest in me and
gave me a little golf cart tour and took
me into Judy Garland's new Tomb like
before it was open to the public I got
like all this special was he a gay
groundskeeper he was uh I don't know his
sexual identity actually I I thought we
had some Vibes at certain points but you
got to do the self-esteem thing where
you go he must be gay he didn't lean in
he's got to be gay
oh you guys so I really need a lot of
like practice and help just being single
in general because I think that I don't
I haven't nailed the the far away
flirting have you ever had to put the
tits back in no put the tits back in
they handled it they handed the far away
flirting I was at this restaurant and
the owner and the sushi chef he was like
just sweating in the corner and he was
really cute and the food he served is
really good but he kept like looking in
my direction because I had like a bra
top on with like some like big oversized
pants Esther's oversized lips
and he kept looking my way but I didn't
know I'm really bad with eye contact
because I'm like crazy
I am I'm just kidding she says about
herself I only made it yeah things to
say also make fun of himself but then I
um
I looked at him and I did like the most
awkward like like kind of like claw
thing I was like
and
um I had to get out of there like
immediately because he was like he like
nodded at me he was like Hey like this
and I was like
I just it came out all wrong and I told
my family it was like eat quickly we got
to get out of here was this in the
Philippines yes yeah that is way worse
than my Kendall job I'm telling you
help but that's kind of fun maybe you
thought you were like no like you were
like a blind mute or not blind but maybe
you can't speak and then on my way out
he was like
um he was like hey thanks for coming in
like where are you gonna be later and
like I couldn't bear it I was like I'm
just going home and then I left
but this I could well you don't need to
have a relationship with someone in the
Philippines okay maybe he thought you
were here
just say something yeah you have a job
okay
don't be start dating a guy in the
[ __ ] Philippines we're like oh my God
we gotta shoot every we're flying to the
Philippines every week like okay we're
getting the text can you guys be in the
Philippines this day this day this day
this day
I would be down
Vegas no I think at one of my my core
wounds from kalila is me being like take
me home to the Philippines and she's
like
I don't know we could have core wounds
for each other yeah that's a really fun
concept for me I feel like I could do
that with anyone I know yeah you go my
core wound it's so dark it's so deep
it's so like dramatic wait speaking of
deep and dramatic you guys I had a
trippy experience
I I'm not gonna explicitly say what I
did acid I know it or mushrooms it has
to be mushrooms okay I'll just yesterday
this is what this is a core wound of
mine every episode we've talked about
we've talked about doing shrooms for the
first time together it was I the way I
did them for the first time was a
terrible mistake I think kalila might be
a mistake which is very aggressive are
you tripping as hard as me but if you
don't think wait I have no you'll be
nurturing if you don't think so because
I've never I've never been on it I'd
probably be a mess I'll be the I'll be
the
[Laughter]
that I would book a flight right now to
Vegas to do streams with you guys like
I'm so on board but I wanted to read to
you all I wrote down after my spiritual
experience like what I think of all of
you oh oh I've read my eyes feeling so
I'm going to start with Annie I think
that like your absolute Core Essence of
who you are is to spread and make Joy
like that's literally who you are that's
sweet like Munch like truly just like
boiled down like you just want to spread
them and make Joy it's like that's your
whole thing like whether you're at the
DMV with someone whether you just like
met a barista like you really want to
make everything oh that's so sweet
coming from someone who I've yelled at
thank you but see I know deep down I
know I always very sorry about that I'll
never tell you again no no and then I
love being yelled at Delilah you're
like you're a creative artistic voice
like you are you're you're just a
creative artist and I feel like people
don't necessarily know that you know all
the comments are like why she's not a
comedian it's like you don't get it
you're stupid like she's a creative
artist Russell does not read the
comments and all we're doing is like
bringing her the comments
no but you you know what I mean that's
yeah Angel thing she's not it's like
she's funnier and smarter than everyone
I know like but yeah creative artist
like because your poems and like I think
there's so much there's so much you have
to express like I feel like we haven't
even started to see like what your
creativity will share oh thanks Esther
and then the guys I did you guys too but
it's not as good
oh my God I can't wait Carlos's was the
hardest because they were fighting it
your body was like I don't want to do it
Carl this is a little okay P your Core
Essence is to just keep everyone safe
um you just like keep us all safe we
could take more risks but thank you it's
your show Daddy yeah no he can't Handler
remember the night there was a night
where I think it was just me Annie and
Carlos and like like staying too long
and poor Pete was just like keeping us
safe yeah the computer okay and then
Carlos I will I will say that I have
pitched like live creatures and he has
kept you safe really but be it live
creatures I knew it okay Carlos this is
a little weird I just wrote down okay so
Carlos is a hardcore Texas Mexican
who had to come to LA to be near Jewish
people
[Laughter]
she's crying he's like that's the most
beautiful thing
I feel like you were raised in Texas
like all these like tough guys
but that was so not who you are but it's
still in there because that's how you
were raised but like you literally had
no choice but to come to LA and like be
friends with like Benji and Sandy and me
like little Jews that that's like where
you thrive I like that yeah you do soak
up the Jew in a good way you're a good
juice sponge but I found out when I met
his sister that when he was born he when
he was really little he lived in Mexico
City and that is so weird were you like
Chick-fil-A Chiclets no he had bad
allergies there and I'm like that's why
he connects with me and other Jewish
people well also it's like the altitude
there is so high like everyone's like
barely breathing yeah we lived like in a
high-rise it was yeah oh my God he's
like we were so rich I forgot to remind
you guys we were really so rich it's
like chick Liz anyone we own the
Chick-fil-A Factory anyone who has a
story of I used to live in Mexico City
or death usually comes like for money
including me like my my parents live
there there in the 80s and that's why my
sister was born there because my dad had
put a lot of money into like the Mexican
cartel yeah the cartel wait really yeah
yeah so I have like that's just like we
can get free drugs
I do feel like I've gotten along with
you better since I had a sinus infection
coming from
it's such a weird thing I talked about
this I shot my first episode of
anniewood I'm like so excited I feel
like so high off of it because I've been
so scared to do it it's just like it's
just like fear to like put yourself out
there like just you and just like all my
ideas but the set is so cute I'm so
excited about it and it was so fun with
Todd and we did last night but I talked
about this a little bit on there or more
in depth on there but I want to talk
about it here too because you're my
girls but I just feel so happy right now
like I just feel so
the way that my relationship with my
family is so unbelievable and so a place
I never thought I would get and now
everything just seems to make sense and
everything was worth it and everything's
so good I had this experience yesterday
that felt like I was on Ayahuasca my mom
okay so I flew my parents to Arizona
because my aunties live in Arizona and
my aunts were not getting along they
haven't talked in years and so my dad
was having a lot of anxiety because he
feels really like you know responsible
for them because he's their older
brother
and so like last time I went to Arizona
I had to see them separately and stuff
but they decided that it was okay and
they were gonna like hang out so we all
hung out together I flew my parents
first class they've never flown first
class before it was so cute they were so
excited my parents came because once
they get it they'll never go back like I
really need to take out a mortgage I
don't have a house
I have to get a second mortgage on this
cop okay
because I I must I have a Daddy Warbucks
complex I realized and I am like this is
all I'm doing for it I just want to get
as rich as possible to just make it rain
for everyone and so flew them first
class it was so exciting put them up at
this hotel I had a weekend in um at the
Tempe Improv it was so fun it was my
second weekend there that I like I don't
I don't know if I sold out all the shows
but it was like really a great a great
weekend where I sold out most of the
shows and then my aunt and uncle who are
like tea party Fox News like hardcore
like religious not I mean no I guess
they are pretty religious but people
that I would be like scared to see my
set that's like you know 75 about my
[ __ ]
they came this was the second year in a
row they came and they laughed their
[ __ ] asses off my whole family was
like dying laughing so proud of me and I
was like I can never be seeking the
approval of anyone else ever again like
if I start seeking the approval of other
people now I know that that's a bad
habit that I have that I have to stop
because all of the people
who when I was a kid didn't give me
quote unquote the things that I needed
or whatever that caused these sort of
anxious attachments that I have they are
here for me they 100 support me now
there's no
it's full love unconditional love
acceptance so if I start going back into
those stories with like what internet
com like anything it's that's on me
because there's just no denying that I'm
getting everything I want so anyone or
that I've ever like desired so anyway so
we had this amazing time we went to like
Escape rooms it was so fun you can watch
anyone we talked more about it but then
so we um
so that my mom was telling me she wrote
a book over the pandemic about just like
a little girl who grows up in the turn
of the century and she ends up working
at a Mill and years ago my mom and dad
and I had gone and like checked out this
Mill and my mom was asking all these
questions doing research for this book
so she's been working on it for a while
and so she wrote this book over the
pandemic and I never pay attention to my
mom's stuff that much you know I'm like
self-absorbed and but I you know I kind
of like listen and then she was telling
me she's like yeah I do this thing where
I read chapters of my book to a bunch of
my girlfriends and they over zoom and
they give me notes I was like oh that's
so cool and then she just sent me a
Google calendar invite and I was
cleaning my house yesterday and I was
like oh I'll just like partner was like
oh I won't listen I was like my mom
wants me to listen and my mom will be
gone one day and I will be like so
pissed I didn't join this thing
and then is it George I feel the same
way
but so
um so I just like joined the thing while
I was cleaning my apartment and it was
like the most beautiful thing I've ever
heard it was my mom reading a book that
she created into my [ __ ] ears I was
crying so hard I was couldn't stop
crying I was like it was like the most
love I've ever felt in my life like I
felt like I was like back in the [ __ ]
womb or something like my mommy reading
me like a story it was so precious and I
was like I will like cherish this for
the rest of my life and I have to
remember that every time I'm like I
don't want to do that for someone or
like like to really like revisit why I'm
feeling that and why I'm having the
resistance and to maybe just surrender
to it because it was [ __ ]
unbelievable it was so beautiful and
then at the end they're all like giving
her notes and I just started like crying
I was like Mom I can't believe this and
her friend goes I feel like when you're
on here I feel like I'm talking to Abby
from high school and I was like from
high school it's her [ __ ] high school
friends are there it's her friends from
high school my mom's 71 years old she
wrote a [ __ ] book over the panda your
mom is so cool she's [ __ ] amazing my
mom is amazing she's an amazing artist
she put aside all of these talents of
hers to like raise me and my brothers
and now she's just taking it back and
and doing it she has friends from from
um High School there friends from
college friends from
um doing Landmark friends from her
Woman's Group she's an Elders group like
my mom is a [ __ ] G she has like
collected and kept friends her entire
life that all are so excited to hear the
book they're like it's so fun like
they're like Abby thank you so much for
doing this it's not like a weird thing
like it's like it feels like such an
even exchange it's just so
that was just so amazing and my dad was
sitting next door I didn't even know I
was like Dad why the [ __ ] aren't you
here I text I was like Dad I'm watching
moms think she's amazing he's like she's
incredible and then I saw his little arm
he was like her tech support sitting
next to her it was just like
that makes me happier than seeing um
older people with a really strong
Community behind them I know like
sometimes you fear like getting older
alone and you see when you see like if I
were to see my parent having that much
support from people she's known since
high school that would that would really
really like warm my heart yeah and it's
like incredible because they're all
going through stuff too she's like well
so-and-so has Parkinson's and so and so
is like husband is on dialysis and it's
like they all have like this time to
meet up and and they're they're the Ebbs
and flows of Life they've seen it all
but I think what's really sweet is when
you said
um that you felt like your mom was like
reading something to you and all of a
sudden you were kind of thrown back to
being that child that made me needed it
so much and isn't it weird that even in
your late 30s like those childhood
wounds can heal even though you think
they're there forever and it's a core
wound that will never close up it's like
it it can and it will and sometimes in
the most unexpected way
and yeah that is like so so [ __ ]
sweet it's just unbelievable it was like
so I was like I can't believe this I was
just like bawling it was so precious I
just like got to see my mom as like a
full person you know that is so cool I'm
just so inspired and I agree with you
about like having Community
I sometimes wish my parents had more of
that even like because you think maybe
you take up their time how could they
possibly but I I agree it's like that's
all I want for everyone in my life they
have Jai wolf they have jobs
like I want that for everyone that I
love for everyone to have a community
exactly what you just explained your mom
has like I wish that for everyone
because that's so important to like our
Humanity yeah and our spirit yeah
yeah I'm really impressed with that and
it's cool to like I feel very fortunate
because even though I had a lot of like
trauma and stuff and and felt really
like abandoned by my parents at times
it's I'm glad that I'm at a place where
they're still living and I can reconcile
that because I know a lot of people have
to do that after their parents pass away
and um which you can still do and then
some people have
on don't bore me my Spotify thing on
Mondays like people have told me some
crazy stories about their parents and I
know that there's like people that have
families where it's like it's not
healthy to to heal it with them you have
to heal it on your own but and I respect
that so much people that can step away
from their family and like take their
own life not take their own life but
take themselves back you know so I don't
want to say like you have to forgive
your parents but if there is a chance
[ __ ] forgive them yeah
I think so sorry that I brought it to
aware no no no no I also like one opened
Anna break
foreign
thank you
when I like think about
I don't know how quite to articulate
this but like basically
like how do I say this
the most cared four I've ever felt when
I like go back in therapy I've done this
exercise
and it was like when I had to go home
for lunch during a play rehearsal on a
Saturday in high school and my mom like
made me lunch
and there was something about that where
I was like busy and stressed out with
this important thing at school and then
like racing home and like my mom being
there to make me a meal that
is just such an emotionally charged
memory of like I wish I still had that
or like that was so a way I felt love
which I feel similar to what you're
saying like your mom reading to you
there's just this like care that you get
or something I don't know you're smart
what do you think that's exactly what
you described of like that like your
body knows where home is like you don't
have to intellectualize you don't have
to ask where home is when you're home
your body just knows it you feel it like
you just feel it like so deeply in your
gut and that's exactly how I feel when I
go home to the Philippines and let me
tell you it's not the same island I grew
up in I grew up in a very
um peaceful very not like not a really
big city it was still very like parts of
it were still very provincial and quiet
and I go back now and it's worse traffic
than L.A so much of it is like
completely like
dilapidated broken down it's a third
world country you know like it's not
it's not for the faint of heart
basically
but when I look at just like
all of the chaos and all of this is it's
a it's a really broken country it's in a
broken Island I go home and I'm like
what the [ __ ] happened here but no
matter how broken it is like I'm just
able to like breathe and and and feel
like you know when Dr Drew came on and
said that like I'm not in my own body a
lot of times and I'm always just
surviving the moment and I I only have
like I only see things after they happen
or I can only make sense of what what I
can only make sense of a moment after
it's happened because I'm just surviving
it over there I'm so in my body like I
see things I'm able to like
like
process things as they're happening and
it's such a weird feeling but it's like
home is home you you no matter where it
is whether it's Skokie whether it's on a
zoom with your mom whether it's in a
dilapidated you know third world Island
like home is home there's nothing you
can do about it I believe that and I
can't tell if this is about to
contradict or support it but basically
when I was in high school we got this
writing prompt that was like home if
home is where the heart is like where is
your home and I remember thinking like
well then it's obviously my childhood
home but then you start to think and
you're like well that could burn down
like that could we could no longer
afford to keep it like there's all these
ways that you could lose it and I'm like
that's so scary so then I don't have
like that's if home is where the heart
is and my heart is in this place that
can be burned down like that's really
terrifying and so I had to sort of
adjust my framework there and be like
well actually like my home has to be a
feeling inside of me now that doesn't
mean that I can't still go there and
like get a fulfillment but I have to
always be safe and comfortable knowing
that like I might never get to go back
to somewhere that I believe is my home
my parents sold my childhood home when I
was 20 and I was so devastated it was
like they had to paint over like the
wall where all of our like heights were
and stuff I mean I was like the people
were buying the house and I was throwing
myself on the stairs crying like I was
like no like it was crazy I was way too
old to be doing it I know you can relate
but but I sometimes I just walk through
it you know like in my head I think
that's it that's exactly I go through my
I I it's still always there you know
there's this like Welsh word called here
here I think it's like
um it's like loving a place you can't go
back to
or it's like having feeling for a place
like you can't go back to but when I was
in the Philippines sickness yeah but
it's like a different kind of
homesickness it's something that you
know you cannot go back to or you don't
even know but when I was in the
Philippines let's be what you said about
the the writing prompt makes sense
because even if I go back to the
Philippines there's no way in hell I am
walking past my old street because so
many horrible I tried to a couple years
ago walk past this yellow house on
malavi street and I felt like I was
gonna vomit like so many horrible things
happen to me there so many family
tragedies happen I dream about it
constantly my nightmares are all about
this yellow house like I have there's
just chronic nightmares about it so no
that's not home even though I grew up
there at home is a Feeling
it's a feeling and sometimes it can
exist in the place and it can exist in a
zoom meeting so I think you're right you
and home can be many places it doesn't
just have to be one and home can be a
person sorry I thought that you lived
with your mom
good timing honestly
whoa that is so crazy to think honestly
I
wish I could
um but she's too like
OCD and symmetry like everything I
couldn't like leave a banana peel for
two seconds on the table it would be a
problem your eye makeup looks great did
you do it in response to not wearing eye
makeup last week what happened last week
was you look cute dumb no no it was I
went full Panda because what happened
was I had intended to put makeup so I
put the primer on the white stuff and it
made it look even but it made it crazy
here it's like oh look it was a look
I've been watching Married at First
Sight and um
who's in it this season there's this cop
yeah there's this couple that's like
the guy's like an environmentalist and
and like an extreme environmental it's
like it's so annoying and he's such a
nerd and like not hot but he's like told
her in the beginning he wasn't attracted
to her which was and she's like
she's like really cool and like huge
tits and cool and awesome and huge tits
I'm like you're so lucky at this huge
titted [ __ ] but uh are you good looking
no he's like a weird bald
and um and he's fine like no judgment on
anyone like they're all fine it's you
know they're obviously like you know
interested in some weird [ __ ] if they're
gonna do Married at First Sight but he
so the first week he tells her he's not
attracted to her and so obviously that's
like a wound and then
um they kind of like work through it and
he gets intern stuff but then he's like
meeting up with her sister and it's like
I don't know how many weeks they're
married but it's like you know a couple
weeks before the decision day and he so
everyone's talking to like someone close
to the their spouse to kind of get like
last minute things and he talks to her
sister and he goes I'm wondering if you
can help me speak to her about like I'm
really like more into hippie girls and I
just think she's so much more beautiful
without makeup and her sister's like
halt
her sister was like excuse me we don't
wear makeup for you [ __ ] like right we
don't change our appearance to like
attractive it was so crazy because he
thought he was being so nice and
generous like I like her the way she is
and it's like why would she have to
change and then she her sister told her
and then she just gave it to her and I
was like so I was like oh [ __ ] go good
but I was just thinking about that I
have a question for you guys
um if you were forced hypothetically if
you were forced in that position where
you had to marry on First Sight like I
could deal with anyone I ever meet what
they would be divorcing and running
like
is that the right route to take to be
like hey like just so you know like I
don't have a natural attraction to you
or do you just hold that in
you don't have to tell them that
you might want to let them know I want
to be let's get more attract let's do
attractive things like I have dated so
many physically hideous men okay but you
probably had a chemistry match with them
that made you feel attracted to them
still I was not attracted to them for 10
years and then they made their move and
we were already moving in together and
it was weird
and I was like am I gonna move back in
my car oh my God I guess we're dating
um I ended up fine but like I
I've had us I've had situations where I
was not attracted to the person and I
became attracted to them yeah
so I know that that's possible and stuff
but to tell someone you're not attracted
to them no see that's you it that your
story of what you just said is exactly
why it's like look I'm not feeling it
yet right like let's get there because I
actually I watched Haley Bieber on call
her daddy and she said something about
Justin Bieber that I really related to
which was that he like has to like have
a conversation before they have sex and
I'm like that's so me like I need to be
like vibing like I mean I need to be
like in a we need to be I'm like doing a
podcast like would you be talking in
front of microphones before I can really
jump into it seem to be running and
donut at my side I no I
like so I do think that
if I wasn't attracted to the person but
we could like really engage on an
intellectual silly level
there's no problem
um I don't know because even if we
intellectually engage and even if they
were attractive just the Aesthetics were
right I'm such a
a Ascent person like uh if it's so weird
it's like if your scalp smell doesn't
match
ceremony yeah if it's like a direct
pheromone match then it's just not
there's just nothing I can do about that
even if they're like making you laugh
and you're connecting and you're like
you guys both like the same
kind of things and you're just having
such a deep connection yeah because then
I would just be like let's be friends
let's be really close friends but like I
can't imagine being like too physically
close with them
I don't know it's just I think we should
test it and we should all have to marry
a stranger and see who gets horny first
that's just one episode this is for one
episode we do it we I do want to for a
second go back to the conversation about
like you going back to the Philippines
because this is one of my favorite
subjects of like going back home and it
reminds me of this quote that is like my
ultimate ultimate favorite quote I think
it's by Gertrude Stein and it says it's
there is no there there
and it basically what it says is the way
she meant it has to do with spending
part of her childhood in a certain part
of Oakland and then leaving and coming
back years later to find it developed
over and unrecognizable so it's like
there is no there there like what you
are picturing and thinking of and
wanting to be it's not there and I find
that that's like a hard life lesson I've
had to learn it's like this thing that
I'm romanticizing and fantasizing about
from my past like it's not there you
can't go back I feel like I've even
brought this up on this show before but
like
I don't know I guess it's and yeah I
just wanted to share that yeah I think
that's interesting but I think it's so
much of of that there you're looking for
is really just in the
um for me it's a lot with
it's the people it's like my my older
sister lives in the Philippines
sometimes there's not there there either
yeah they're there
where was their hair there camp
counselor story but being around like my
cousins and them like
um connecting the dots for me that maybe
some like memories were blurry for me
and we were all laughing about it they
were you know what we were laughing
about over dinner like hysterically was
a time I ran away from home and hid in a
trash can for three hours because my mom
was chasing me trash Tuesday dude it's
in my blood I'm the original Filipino
raccoon because
um it took them three hours to find me I
was so afraid my mom was just gonna beat
my ass for something so small like
leaving a shampoo bottle did you use the
thing as a shield where you're like it
started trying to stop you started doing
a dance
and so them just like retelling the
story and everyone having their own
account of it like putting bits and
pieces of information together just and
I try to blur that out so much but for
them to kind of just make it a vivid
memory again and then us like cry
laughing about it and you work through
it and we call my mom and then she's
laughing about it and I'm like you hey
in this [ __ ]
and she was like I do remember but your
mom was beat that way too right oh worse
than me way worse than me so yeah
there's a lot of I accept you know why
she did it she didn't know any better
but you know it's it's it's you know
everything tracks you go home and you're
like oh this is why I'm so you know this
is why this is why I am who I am and it
just everything just makes sense you
connect the dots about yourself did your
dad protect you from her
um
she did most of the stuff when he was
away
um he was very Stern and I was probably
most afraid of him because he was very
like he had a very big voice but he
never beat us my mom was the person who
just was relentless
um
but
yeah maybe there's no there there just
kill myself oh my God way to go Esther
what are the poem that makes her kill
herself
it was like when I went home no I never
do another poem It's Gonna Make You Want
To Live hold on
revive me Annie revive this is my
favorite poem
and a lot of people hate it I don't know
why so you type on your phone my nails
are in a full Nightmare and I have
grease from the olives Oliver she's
doing this it's a full nightmare with
these nails
all right
come on
come on
all right when you are old by William
Butler Yates when you're old and gray
and full of sleep and nodding by the
fire take down this book and slowly read
and dream of the soft look your eyes
once had and of their Shadows deep how
many loved your moments of glad Grace
and loved your beauty with love false or
true but one man loved the pilgrim soul
in you and loved the Sorrows of your
changing face and bending down beside
the glowing bars murmur a little sadly
how love fled and paced upon the
mountains overhead and hid his face
Among the Stars that isn't that sweet
it's not getting old and I don't know
maybe it's about a man maybe that's bad
but no but they be old don't kill
yourself yeah don't be young no but I
felt strong enough to feel weak does
that make sense yeah yes like I went
home and I was like oh I'm like I could
acknowledge how like broken and weak I
was like over here you just think that
you've got to be this you can't care
about this you can't care you've got to
show strength you gotta be this I'm like
when I went home I was like oh my God
like I'm so sad and in secure but I felt
strong enough to say it out loud there I
don't feel strong enough to say it out
here because I feel like
um maybe that will be preyed on in a
different way I'm safe but when I was
there and getting my hair brushed
nightly I was like oh my God like I'm
just a sad sad baby
and that's okay yeah I'm so hurt I'm so
everything hurts me I'm hypersensitive
everything affects me but I don't want
to say it out loud so then you're just
silently suffering yeah but I think I'm
okay now to say out loud that like to be
like I'm [ __ ] sensitive I cry so much
every tiny thing every [ __ ] shift of
a wind affects me and [ __ ] it that's
just I'm a fragile little thing it's
okay yeah I'm fragile I'm not [ __ ]
strong or Macho I'm tired of burrowing
down I'm just a fragile little thing
just surrender to who you are it's all
good yeah perfect
now baby me oh my God you're at the baby
in the show anymore you're like you're
like English and then help me
oh one and
one and yes like my mom just kidding I
wouldn't breastfeed only one so I got
one hanger I think I have a get rich
quick scheme for us and it has to do
with this article I saw can I can I just
fix your grammar get richer quicker yes
thank you actually thank you about
unsolicited dick pics
and there's a new law in California I
think
that basically says that women can sue
men for sending them an unsolutely I'm a
[ __ ] billionaire move over and you
were the first person I thought of The
Flash law
so up to thirty thousand dollars you
know why I would I it's not that see if
you said random dick pics there's no
proof that that it's that person's penis
but so many guys these days have their
face all the dick pics that they show me
have part of their face on it so there's
actually that's when you know they're
truly mentally ill it's like you are
[ __ ] so crazy you're asking for a
lawsuit yeah my favorite dick pic I mean
I don't like any of them but my favorite
that was sent to me was this guy had his
heels together like this
and his penis was resting over his heels
and it was
so disgusting it was so bad
it was so so we can't we get paid
retroactively for all the peanuts we've
had to endure on Earth right now can you
see the same person for continuously
sending them I don't know but I'm just
saying like if I get one or if you guys
got one like I'm pursuing I'm gonna I'm
gonna on I'm gonna start allowing DMS
now yeah my question is where does the
30k come from the person is unlikely to
have that just you know like really
faith in these dick pics guys I mean
look I just the fact that they're
humiliated they're sex offenders it is a
sec it is sexy it's so annoying okay so
one time this is a story I want to tell
you guys so I was on
um there used to be a podcast called
race Wars with Sherrod small and Kurt
Metzger and I was on it and I was
talking I said directly on there I don't
want dick pics okay but we were looking
at like
we were looking at um Michael Phelps
like
Speedo or something and we were talking
about penises and I was going I don't
like dick pics like I was saying it as
we were talking about it
um this is to give this person any sort
of leeway like maybe he misheard me and
said I love dick pics and I was like I
hate them please do not ever and then so
um this guy sends me a dick pic and I'm
incensed I can't believe it after I just
had spent like five minutes doing like
this whole diatribe about how I don't
like dick pics I don't know what the
word dye tribe means but it's the first
time I said it anyway
um and then so so I was so pissed that I
had just so blatantly said I didn't want
it and then he did it it was such a
violation that I screen grabbed the dick
pic and I posted it on his Facebook one
with his name sending it to me and he
freaked out for some reason he had
Kurt's phone number or got hurt some and
then he's on the phone and Kurt's like
talking and he's like you know I'm a
teacher like how could you do this I was
like can you explain to him that the
incident started with him and all of our
issues with men that we've had on this
podcast let's remember the issue started
with you doing a thing okay our
reactions to it cannot be something that
we're in trouble for you do a thing
there are consequences
that is the most yeah epic thing that
anyone I know has ever done and for him
to be like I'm a teacher you I don't
care
I said no and he was like I was just
kidding it's not funny
I was kidding it's these guys where it's
like how could you do this to me you
started it you sent the picture or the
DM or the request or whatever you
started it you did the bad thing we
reacted to it
okay we're allowed to react we're full
humans that are allowed to have
experiences and talk about them if we
want and we don't have to leave names
out we can actually say the names if we
want oh bring names back 2022. we're
going to start saying I'm just kidding
all my guy friends block me
well
welcome back to me welcome back to me
welcome back to you Annie hi guys fun
I'm so happy to be reunited with you
guys you have no idea my life has been
very sad and lonely being rejected at
parties I needed you guys like I need
this it's we needed this though this
story is getting me through
your rejection is such a win for me
Esther I
um what was I gonna [ __ ] say what
have we learned today we're getting rich
off dick pics rich off the deck packs
home is inside of you home isn't it
Carlos stuck it we stuck it in Carlos
Carlos stuck it inside of me your ears
Carlos and kalila took it to the next
level and Bobby is genuinely really
pissed
guys everyone's super mad and there's a
real drama
and this isn't wrestling you [ __ ]
dings
yeah I love you and guys be for good
luck
in all honesty and seriousness we
appreciate our happy positive slugs out
there so much we could not do this
without you and the fact you guys come
back every single week means so much to
all of us we are always thinking of you
and we will see you guys next week hell
yeah and I wasn't depressed the episode
with Ashley I was on Xanax and I felt
like my arms were really long laughs
[Music]
[Music]